I think that this was something but
personally I didn't vote for it marks
the end of a period of over 40 years
where we've been in a certain set of
relationships but my own view is that
the vote happened the vote has to be
respected it was a huge fact that has
changed things and therefore our task as
a country is to come together and get on
with implementing brexit as
intelligently as we can and as fast as
we can
how ready are both sides for the
negotiations well I think both sides
clearly have spent the last nine months
also getting themselves in order but for
me I think the biggest question is
what's the spirit into which both sides
are entering this and what is the
mindset as to whether or not actually
they want to do a deal I believe that if
both sides do want to do some kind of
deal and I think it's in the interests
of both sides to do one then you'll end
up concluding something because the
European system above all is a
negotiating system and I think that once
it starts we're likely to find our way
through to a sensible conclusion so for
me the big question is the first period
the next three to six months to try and
make sure that we do get off to a
sensible start and hotheads don't drive
the agenda one way or the other the
hotheads to which you referred on this
side of the channel or are they in
Brussels I think there are people on
both sides who start from totally
opposed positions ideologically but both
have an interest in things in the
negotiations being you know nasty
brutish and short and so I think it's on
both sides and so I think the risk
magnified by our media is that rhetoric
escalates and makes sensible compromise
harder to achieve now Michele Barnea the
--use chief negotiator has said that he
wants us to agree a divorce bill before
we proceed with other parts of the
negotiations is that something on which
the UK is going to have to give way well
I see myself I see it all as part of a
package I
see how you can talk about leaving
without also talking about the future at
the same time I do see it as part of the
whole they're clearly going to be
discussions about money and I think the
British government said that we accept
there are some obligations we've entered
into that will honor and I think you
need to honor those in terms of your
international reputation but I see all
of these elements as being linked and so
for me the key question isn't to get
fixated on particular elements of them
it's to say do we want to get a deal is
it in Europe and Britain's interest to
sort this out sensibly would it send a
good message to the rest of the world
for the EU if they can resolve this
amicably because they're big priority is
how do you get growth going how do you
grapple with some of the other issues
they've got so I don't think it's in
their interests any more than Britain's
to spend years and years beating each
other up over this now as commissioner
you held the financial services
portfolio how optimistic are you about
the city's future post brexit well I
think the best way I can answer that
question is by telling you what people
in the city have said to me and I think
in the immediate aftermath of the of the
vote I think they were concerned before
the vote there was a kind of a uniform
view that they thought we'd be better
off staying in and in the single market
I think by the autumn we were starting
to see a more differentiated picture so
that different sectors have a different
feeling about the future depending on
how they are likely to be affected and
within sectors some banks are more
relaxed about it than other banks for
example so I think the predominant mood
is that the city will come through this
that people I think businesses are
looking at how can you move as little as
possible for as long as possible
I don't think there is going to be a
kind of light switch I don't think at
the beginning with some people were
saying this means the end of London a
Renaissance for Paris or for Frankfurt I
don't believe
that's going to happen for a variety of
reasons I think London is full of a huge
amount of extremely talented people from
all over the globe and when you put lots
of clever people in a small space they
tend to be able to find ways of
regenerating themselves and being
successful so I think that's what will
happen but do you accept that there will
have to be job cuts in the city well
that's going to be a decision for the
businesses involved it looks at the
moment likely there going to be some job
loss it's the scale at the moment looks
at the low end of the spectrum so far
compared with what people were saying in
advance but I think the honest answer is
it's early days and some of it will
depend on where we end up in terms of
you know the basis of which we agree the
terms that financial services in
particular will carry on trading with
each other obviously you resigned as a
commissioner shortly after the brexit
votes what did your resignation achieve
I resigned for one simple reason which
was I think that in politics and in
business there is a feeling widespread
and deserved that when things go wrong
people at the top don't resign and I
thought it was just completely
unthinkable that when something as big
as brexit happens the Britain's
Commissioner could sit there as though
nothing had happened I mean that for me
would have summed up everything that
people thought about the system so I
thought it was the right thing to do on
grounds of principle I also think from a
practical point of view on financial
services where I was trying to reform
financial services make them more market
orientated outward-looking
that it would not have been possible for
a Brit to carry on regulating financial
services when financial services are
going to be a key part of any discussion
that we have with our European friends
on the terms of our leaving so I think
practically it wouldn't have been
possible either would you like to be
participating in the exit negotiations I
think that this is one thing where I'm
very happy having stuck my hands in the
mango over the last six years in the
British government to leave others to do
it and I think that we need people who
whether it's in business as well who
have friends in Europe to keep talking
to them to try and keep routes of
communication open because the more that
there are sensible rational voices the
more likely we are to have a sensible
outcome to the negotiation now you're in
the process of organizing the prosperity
UK conference what's that all about and
what do you hope to achieve from it it's
a bunch of levers and remainders who've
come together I think both of us share
the same frustration that the political
debate in the UK seems to be a bit stuck
and that people are in politics
rerunning the referendum vote by proxy
and I think that you have to accept the
outcome of the result then the challenge
is ok how are we going best to adapt to
this deal with any problems make the
most of any opportunities and ask
yourself what kind of economy what kind
of society do we want to be what
strengths can we have as an economy and
how can we build on it so the idea is to
build bring together business who I
think I've got a much quicker to respond
and to adapt than politics because they
have to be every day to come together be
honest and realistic about the
challenges be optimistic about the
opportunities and come up with practical
suggestions constructive thinking as to
how we can try to move things forward
we've had a fantastic response from
business everyone we've asked to come
and speak has said yes unless they're
physically you know out of the country
and I hope it will mark you know the
beginning of a more constructive
approach to how we think and talk about
some of these issues